there's been a wave of arrests of people
who police say threatened to carry out
mass shootings after this month's
massacres in Dayton and El Paso the
suspects include a truck driver in
Indianapolis who allegedly threatened to
shoot and stab people at a Tennessee
church and a 15 year old in Florida
accused of posting a mass shooting
threat on a video game platform CBS News
senior national security analyst Fran
Townsend was a homeland security and
counterterrorism adviser for president
george w bush frame good morning where
these threats some of them may just be
people being more observant and and
reporting more about possible threats
out there it's alarming though are we
are we facing an epidemic here it is an
epidemic there's no question there's a
rise in anti-semitism racism we're
seeing these attacks not only in the
United States the rise but also in
Europe I think what we're what we need
to understand as many of the lessons
learned about fighting international
terrorism apply here domestically right
you see something you say something and
so if it's a young person it's your it's
your teacher it's your classmates if
you're an older person it's your spouse
it's your community it's your employer
and you have to encourage people I think
people now understand that they can play
a role in preventing these other things
missing in the u.s. to help fight the
the domestic terrorism issue that law
enforcement needs well no question right
that we had all these authorities when
we were fighting international terrorism
that we thought well do we really want
to apply those here in the United States
I think there are privacy and civil
liberties concerns there are First
Amendment concerns I think we've got to
get over that and I think we have to
understand that there's a balance but
we've got to give law enforcement both
the resources and the authorities they
need do we have to have another
conversation about what it really looks
like I think for many times people think
of terrorists and they think from a
foreign country they may think
darker-skinned these last arrests these
last three that were reported to to
yesterday
the mother was saying he's a little boy
he wouldn't think this way they have all
been white men do we need to have a real
conversation about what we're dealing
with here let's be honest Gail look I
think when it's a when the terrorist is
a white person we tend to make excuses
right okay they're crazy yeah
crazy right as opposed to saying if it
was a Muslim there are terrorists we
have to label this for what it is and
we've got to be honest and not make
excuses and again when you look at the
international fight we used to look at
what are the enablers you take away
their guns you take away their
communications you take away their
ability to recruit while domestic
terrorism isn't as hierarchical and
organized in that way there's
responsibilities both to take away their
guns right and make that less accessible
to have social media sites where they
post these hateful manifestos take those
down and notify law enforcement what
does law enforcement need to get at
these things that they don't have that
they have maybe in international cases
but not domestically so I mean this has
got to do with surveillance capability
subpoena capability all of that I think
they've begun to shift the resources
because they see the increasing problem
but I think we've at the federal level
they've been slow to do that I think at
the local level where police officers
are responding to these incidents
there's been a quicker shift and so I do
think it's also a matter of I'm struck
by the mother with the little boy who
said he's a little boy he wouldn't do
that he's not crazy but all the experts
say there are specific warning signs
that we should be looking out for that's
exactly right so they they will post
things on social media they will say
they will actually say to classmates or
to family members that they were going
to get a gun that they wanted to have a
shooting they want to kill people those
are the sorts of things we've got to
take seriously and have people reporting
those alright Fran Townsend thank you
very much we appreciate it thank you